SO INCOMPETENT.
AT TIMES, SEEMS THEY’RE DOING
WHATEVER THEY CAN TO KEEP IT
SPREADING.
HE WOULD LIKE TO INVESTIGATE THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION FOR
WHAT IT’S DONE IN RESPONSE TO
THIS PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
TELL US WHY YOU BELIEVE THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION IS
CULPABLE FOR THIS DISASTER.
>> FIRST OFF, THEY WORK FOR
CHINA, COMMUNIST CHINA.
AT FIRST THEY SAID IN A TWEET
THAT THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE THAT
THERE WAS HUMAN TO HUMAN
TRANSMISSION.
A LIE.
THEN THEY SAID ON THE 20TH OR
SOMETHING, CHINA’S DOING A GREAT
JOB.
LIE.
I ASKED THEM WHEN TRUMPED AT THE
RIGHT THING BY DOING THE TRAVEL
BAN EMMA THEY ATTACKED TRUMP FOR
DOING THE WRONG THING.
I ASKED HIM TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION OF CHINA BACK IN
FEBRUARY, IF THEY HAD DONE THEIR
JOB, EVERYONE WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
MORE READY.
AND WE WOULDN’T HAVE ALL THESE
PEOPLE DEAD ALL OVER THE WORLD.
SO I AM ON HOMELAND SECURITY,
TALK TO THE CHAIRMAN
RON JOHNSON, HE’S AGREED TO DO
IT.
WE ARE GOING TO INVESTIGATE WHY
DID THEY DO WHAT THEY DID, WHAT
WAS THEIR PURPOSE AND THEN WHY
ARE WE AS AMERICAN TAXPAYERS
GIVING THEM SOME OF OUR DOLLARS?
>> Tucker: BILL GATES THE
SINGLE LARGEST DONOR WHY ARE
THEY STILL TREATED AS SERIOUS
PEOPLE WHEN SO MANY OF THEM ARE
LIARS AND BUFFOONS.
ONE THING IS WE SHOULD NEVER,
EVER BUY ONE MORE PRODUCT FROM
CHINA.
YOU HAVE TO SAY THAT’S A GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT COMPLETELY LIE TO
US AND FORCED US TO SHUT DOWN
OUR ECONOMY AND KILL AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND ITALIANS AND
SPANIARDS OF CROSS OF STEALING
OUR JOBS.
THEY LIED, THEY WERE RIGHT UP
WITH THEM HELPING.
WHATEVER COMMUNIST CHINA SAID.
>> Tucker: HOW LONG ARE WE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO FUND THIS
ORGANIZATION DO YOU THINK?
>> I HOPE THIS IS THE LAST YEAR.
AND BY THE WAY, NOT ONLY DO I
NOT WANT TO FUND THE W.H.O., I
CAN’T IMAGINE IT’S GOING TO GET
ANY BETTER THAN WHAT WE ALREADY
KNOW.
BUT WHY ARE WE FUNDING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE LYING TO
US?
WE PAY 21% OF THEIR BUDGET.
SO WHAT’S GOING ON HERE?
WHY ARE THEY PARROTING WHAT
CHINA’S DOING AND DO THEY FOLLOW
THEIR PROTOCOL, I DOUBT THEY
FOLLOW IT FOR PANDEMICS AND WHY
DIDN’T THEY DO IT.
FOR A PROTECTIVE GEAR AND
VENTILATORS, THERAPEUTICS, STOP
RELYING ON CHINA FOR ANYTHING.